foreign
Todd joins us up next in Toledo Ohio
Todd welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for having me yeah if
I sound nervous at all this is my first
call with you guys hey we're freaking
out with you man we're we're gonna do
great we're in this together
thank you
well I am a 20 year old kid and I
my mom is going to a foreclosure and
it's forced me and my brother to take
out a loan and I'm wondering if there's
anything that I should do that I may
have not thought of oh Todd I'm so sorry
how did she end up in foreclosure
well during the pandemic we were
kind of in a rough spot and we
hold up um we were forced to basically
get a loan for our house because we
qualified for it and
she ended up using the house as
collateral and she made a late payment
on the loan and she thought it'd be fine
you know just pay like the late fee or
whatever but they were like no there's
no late fee we're going to take your
house unless you can pay back this loan
and the loan was for basically two years
of house payment
and uh so now we owe about
35k to 40K
on it who's we
uh me my brother and my mom so you're
already on this loan
yes I I had to take it out just because
like it's due uh to be paid off uh this
Friday
what's due to be paid off the the thirty
five thousand dollar loan
yes
okay or what
um or you lose the house
yes basically
how much is the house worth
um I believe it's worth 260k
and so you said during the pandemic
you had to take out the loan and you had
the opportunity to was that
to afford your house payments
or what kind of led to the to taking out
the loan
it was basically we
my mom wanted to defer her money it
sounded like a good deal to my mom I
personally wouldn't take out any loan
but she thought it was a good deal and
took out the loan and now we're just
kind of in this situation
so on Friday is the entire loan due or
do you you said they won't take a look
I don't know what kind of shady loan you
guys signed up for but this is a
nightmare Todd and you keep saying that
I we were forced
I've never heard of someone forcing you
to take out a loan
okay it wasn't like a loan shark kind of
thing it was through
um am I allowed to say the name sure
it was through loan care and then it was
some uh
agency that my mom's been using for ever
I I don't know I don't know Todd Todd
well you were you're growing up fast for
20 because this is an adult decision you
made to co-sign on this debt
um and it sounds like you guys are going
to lose this house and we're gonna need
to find some place to rent I would get
in touch with a real estate attorney to
figure out what your rights are if
there's a way to save this thing uh but
you know on a quick call it's hard to
dig into all these details but uh Todd
we didn't want to leave you hanging
there so let's get back to your
situation here so as I understand it you
guys are taking a personal loan out to
cover this 35 40 000 Loan in order to
save the house
correct okay and is that done
uh yes I took out a eight thousand
dollar loan and I also have five 5.05 6
000 and uh personal savings and my
brother had to take out 11k and he had
um
do you have some money and personal
savings yes and that covers the amount
that you guys needed
yes to cover this loan Care Loan and
your mom did she not qualify for
something to cover it why why why is it
you guys responsible for it
because that's exactly right uh she her
credit score is shot and she can't
really get any more money than uh what's
from other than what's from our income
so what what's the actual mortgage
amount
what do you mean because you have the 35
40K loan is there another mortgage as
well on this house
uh yes I don't know how much left is on
it but we've had this house for at least
15 years or so so I'm assuming it's more
than half paid off okay and can your mom
afford the payment what is her income
uh she can't afford the payment it was
uh
her income's about uh
60k a year okay and what is this
mortgage payment she needs to make every
month
I believe it's about
1 500.
okay Enter you both are living there you
and your brother
yes
all right so your your question now
becomes hey we're gonna be able to keep
the house it's not going to get
foreclosed on we're going to pay this
loan off in time to avoid foreclosure
correct which now leaves you guys with
leaves you personally with an 8 000 loan
and no savings
and it leaves your brother with an 11
000 loan and no savings
and then you still have oh I guess they
pay off that loan and that then just
leaves you with whatever mortgage was
originally on the house which is in your
mom's name
yes okay
so you're asking what is the plan going
forward for us to pay this off
all right we can do that now so what is
your income
I make about thirty three thousand
dollars a year okay
your brother makes the same
okay well your A1 is to get a thousand
dollar starter emergency fund both of
you separately thousand bucks in the
bank beyond that we're going to be
tackling these loans do you guys have
any other debt
uh no
that's good news and I assume Mom has
nothing in the bank
uh not really other than low liquidity
stocks
okay so she is she able to sell those
off
not in time for this
because it needs to be all one big
payment by Friday but you guys already
have that money you're saying
okay so I would go ahead and make sure
this loan is cleared in time have you
contacted the lender to let them know
the situation
uh yes okay what's that what's that
discussion been like when you're on the
phone with them
um
basically I'll what they said is I could
probably be able to pay it off as
within the year because I me and my
brother made sure that we got along with
no
um
prepayment penalty so we're just gonna
like as far as our plan goes we're just
gonna try and apply as much money as we
can this year to get them out of our air
you're talking about those personal
loans you guys took out for 8K and 11k
yes okay what about the 35 40 000 loan
that you're paying off to keep the house
it was
the loan basically was
set up in a way to defer our house
payments to the loan so during the time
it's just we're making
we're just kind of paying off the house
in that sense
but when you call this this lendera
about the 35 to 40 000 what's the
conversation like have they threatened
you have they said you have to pay this
by Friday or before like tell me about
that conversation oh no yeah where in
the fine print was it hey if you miss a
payment it's due in full within a week
it was my mom who talked to them and
they they just kind of like
uh
they were just like oh yeah sorry we you
know you didn't make the payment so your
house is in foreclosure kind of thing
they really didn't like if any heads up
on that whole spectrum of you know that
side of the loan Okay this may be an
unpopular opinion but I'm kind of
frustrated with your mom right now like
you're 18 years old and she brought you
into the situation she is clearly not
handling her money well and she is
dragging her sons into this my heart
just hurts for you and I feel frustrated
and right now I'm not gonna trust your
mom's follow-through on this financial
situation your name is on that loan how
do we know this isn't going to happen
again
um basically her plan is to either sell
the house what I want to do with the
house is I want to fix it up and then
make long-term money off of it by
renting it
um
and I I think that would be better but I
don't know what you guys would say on
that matter but here's the thing before
before we leave that I'm calling that
lender myself if I'm in your shoes like
you said your mom called them I want you
to pick up the phone and you to call
them because right now if you and your
brother take out those loans you're
essentially transferring the debt away
from your mother like your mom is on
that for 35k loan she's not gonna be on
this 8K and 11k right
that's putting that debt all in your
name she gets out of that 35 000
scot-free right and she gets to keep
living how she's been living like I'm
not letting her off the hook that easy
like I'm calling that is that is your
loan you call and you see if this is
really true that this whole Friday thing
is true if everything is due and you
have to take out a loan like I want the
details myself firsthand I would pick up
that phone and if it is true that
they're like you gotta pay it by Friday
then I'd say okay we're gonna negotiate
like right they don't want to really go
through foreclosure so then talk to them
and say I mean maybe they do because
they'd be getting a steal on that but I
would still talk to them and say I've
got this much money like will you take
20 right before you put all your savings
into it like see if you can negotiate
like take ownership of this situation it
is your life and your money and it's so
sad that at your age you're having to
deal with this that just
frustrates me to no end but I want to
empower you to take responsibility for
this and actually follow through on all
aspects of this
okay thank you I if I'm in your shoes
you're saying Mom this is too much you
put on us in a terrible financial
situation you put us in debt for your
home and we're selling this thing and
you're gonna go rent somewhere that you
can afford so that you don't get
foreclosed on again and it may be time
for for you and the brother to move out
and get get your own place together
would that work agree yeah because this
is just a toxic situation and my word is
she keeps taking advantage of you guys
financially
yeah
and I think it's so important too like I
you know I'm all about honoring parents
and respecting and all of that and I
know you probably do want a relationship
going forward and if that's the case I'm
also going to say hey Mom we're going to
sit down and take Financial Peace
University like what you're doing with
your life how you're managing your money
the fact that you're in such a mess like
that's not okay we need to sit down
together and clean up this mess like
it's not just going to be on me and my
brother to deal with this you got to sit
down with us like we're gonna get good
with money but so are you like I really
want you to do this with us
gotcha okay like I'm not I would say I'm
pretty good with money personally
because
um as far as a role model because we've
had to grow up fast
yeah I yeah it was like my mom was like
showing me everything not to do and I
was like okay I'm not gonna do this I'm
not gonna do that kind of thing well
part of being good with money Todd is
not co-signing other people's debt and
you put yourself in a precarious
situation and uh you got a great heart
clearly you want to save save the house
and keep mom in there but man this is a
a big stupid tax we're paying and we're
gonna say never again we're gonna change
our family tree